-Performing "Best Days"
from her new album,
"In The Meantime",
once again, Alessia Cara.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ So much harder to be honest ♪
♪ With yourself at
twenty-something ♪
♪ Wish I knew
what I'm becoming ♪
♪ And felt the ground
while I was on it ♪
♪ Hoping, waiting on a moment ♪
♪ Not knowing if it's coming
or it's going, ooh ♪
♪ What if my best days
are the days I've left behind? ♪
♪ And what if the rest stays
the same for all my life? ♪
♪ I'm running with my eyes
closed, so it goes ♪
♪ You live and then you die ♪
♪ But the hardest pill to
swallow is the meantime ♪
♪ Are the best days just
the ones that we survive? ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh,
ooh-ooh ♪
♪ If I had known to
feel the fire ♪
♪ I would've thrown my arms up
higher ♪
♪ Would've held on
a little tighter ♪
♪ 'Cause you don't know a thing
you miss till it's behind you ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-oooh ♪
♪ What if my best days are
the days I've left behind? ♪
♪ And what if the rest stays
the same for all my life? ♪
♪ I'm running with my eyes
closed, so it goes ♪
♪ You live and then you die ♪
♪ But the hardest pill to
swallow is the meantime ♪
♪ Are the best days just
the ones that we survive? ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh,
ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, ye-a-h ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ What if my best days are
the days I've left behind? ♪
♪ And what if the rest stays
the same for all my life? ♪
♪ So what if the best days
are the days I've left behind? ♪
♪ And what if the rest stays
the same for all my life? ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh,
ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, ooh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]